[Music]
94 life that's the motto of the
youngevity company and I'll tell you a
little bit about that in a minute but
basically it represents 60 6-0 minerals
16 vitamins 12 amino acids 3 fatty acids
all vertebrates including human beings
and porpoises and turtles and fish and
flamingos and rabbits and pigs all
vertebrates including humans require
these 90 essential nutrients this is a
disclaimer letting you know that only
God knows everything and then when I
graduated school I knew that I had
something very unique and most doctors
will see 15 25 patients a day if they're
surgeons they might only see three or
four patients a day and I knew that I
could not get the information out just
seeing that many people I need to
leverage my time so I began with the VHS
tapes with the audio cassette tapes the
CDs the book dead doctors don't lie the
CDs in three years time we sold 158
million copies the DVDs are in nine
languages we've sold almost 600 million
copies the book has sold 10 million
copies - going crazy we have a new one
out - dr. Alex media library and this is
to leverage time to teach you to know
what I know so if somebody asks you a
question you will give the exact same
answer that I give so that's what we did
all this then of course have been on
radio 1300 stations for over 25 years
over 25 years I speak to millions and
millions of people over the world 2
hours every day Monday through Friday
for 25 years so it's been a pleasure and
I'm just so amazed at the people who
call in and ask questions about their
health then we also began to leverage
our time by buying other companies they
had good products had good people and we
realized it was a quick way to pick up
ten thousand fifty thousand a hundred
thousand 1 million people to tell the
same message so we acquired in the last
20 years just short of 30 companies we
have 50 countries were in including
Mexico Viva Mexico
Guadalajara we have main offices huh and
we have warehouses and shipping
facilities and stuff and training rooms
and things so as I say we're in 50
countries we're all through Asia Europe
Canada the United States Mexico
Nicaragua Colombia okay all the islands
on the East Coast so it's getting bigger
and bigger better to get the message out
the same message we open the stock
market this year you know we're on the
stock market Nasdaq hmm and they picked
us we didn't pay to be there they picked
us because they know that we were going
to be the Amazon of health care
youngevity is gonna be the Amazon of
health care and we're going to take care
of billions of people using the same
techniques over and over and over this
is me in 1961 I was 21 years old I had
my degree in agriculture I was halfway
through my degree in veterinary medicine
I also started my degree in pathology
and since that was the new boy on the
block everybody else went to Christmas
holidays I was left behind to do at work
and I ran into the first mass die-off in
America from pollution got published and
all the detective read did the foot work
I gave copies to governors and Senators
and to famous people and in 1964 I had
my degree in agriculture my degree in
veteran medicine I was halfway through
my pathology degree I thought I better
go somewhere else to finish my pathology
I didn't want three degrees from the
same University I went to Iowa State
University and Marlin Perkins sent me a
letter from the old mutual Omaha Wild
Kingdom TV show because I'd worked for
him as a kid and he said I need you to
go to Africa and work on the white rhino
conservation project so this picture
represents two years in Africa that's me
we were catching rhinos we caught 200
there was only 470 left at that time
south of the Zambezi River the southern
one-third of the African continent sent
them here so if you see a white rhino in
a zoo it's either one that I caught her
babies from the ones that I caught the
book Rhino Express is the book that
documents the the activities two years
into it I'm prepared to stay in Africa
forever
huh well then Perkins says ruler so look
I just got 25 million dollars from the
National Institutes of Health to study
pollution and zoo animals in big cities
we want to find the zoo animals that
have the same sensitivity to pollution
of humans do we're going to use the zoo
animals in big cities like the old coal
miners used to use Canaries raise your
hand if you've heard about the Canaries
in the coal mines the Canaries coal
miners would take their Canaries down in
the mine in a cage if the pollution
would come in to the mine the Canaries
would die the men do to get out so they
wouldn't be dead so we wanted to use the
the animals in the zoo's like the canary
in the mine so we'll find an animal that
had the same sensitivity to pollution
that we humans did smoked in the United
Nations several times receive Lifetime
Achievement Awards natural medicine
philanthropy this is a cute story about
five years ago I when I came back to the
main office in Chula Vista California
suburb of San Diego
there's nuns there from Mexico from in
Tijuana and it come to me and they would
hug me and kiss me now nuns don't hug
and kiss people so I say why are you
hugging and kissing me am I still on
earth am I in heaven or you welcomed me
to heaven what is going on here
they said the peasants from the
mountains are coming to our churches
they're coming to our churches and
they're asking for the wallach cures so
we're taking the money that's donated to
the churches we're buying your products
we're giving it to the peasants and the
mountains this has not happened since
the days of Jesus oh what a terrible
responsibility I had this is my thesis
represented seventeen thousand autopsies
and 454 species of animals in the big
zoos around nine states in Canada and
Mexico and you can look it up on Amazon
use books and see how much they sell for
when they're new and when they're
damaged what I found out was that all
vertebrates require these 90 essential
nutrients there are no genetic diseases
that was a false theory there are no
genetic diseases we can prevent every
birth defects you can name and most
diseases will get into a moment you'll
be able to reverse just by simple
supplementation with the 90 why do
doctors pick the snake as their logo
Satan came to Eve in the Garden of Eden
as a snake to seduce her to seduce Adam
to come to the devil so why did doctors
take the snake as their logo 2008
another cover article Time magazine the
sorry state of American health right now
America ranks 43rd in the world and
comes to longevity there's 42 other
countries 42 other countries whose
peoples live longer than Americans yet
we spend more money for health care than
all the nations the world combined 207
our kids are not in good shape right now
we ranked 41st and 45th depending on how
many or who you look at and whose work
you look at when it comes to live births
and first month survivability of babies
we knew 19 excuse me 2004 in 2004
American children will die before their
parents
we're in trouble the medical system has
failed us this is a catastrophic
terrible terrible prediction of biblical
proportions
like the firstborn of all the Egyptians
dying because Pharaoh wouldn't release
the Hebrew slaves our children will die
before their parents everybody's gonna
be burying their children if we don't
change what we're doing the biggest
mistake doctors make is Miss diagnosis
where they don't know what you have it's
your genes here we have a genetic
disease our autoimmune your body's
attacking itself 99% of the doctors in
America don't know how to diagnose
diseases they're just taught how to
write prescriptions States rarely
prosecute doctors they rarely punish
them they rarely investigate them
because doctors give more money to PAC
committees to re-elect politicians and
politicians protect doctors so they
won't quit giving of money 80 % of
second opinions by big clinics in
hospitals show the original diagnosis
and treatment plan are incorrect
Mohammed Ali the greatest didn't die
from complications of parkin disease he
had pneumonia he goes to the emergency
room and they gave him intravenous
antibiotics and prednisone before they
pulled the needle out of him
he died of toxic shock syndrome they
killed the greatest or the treatment
great great young man Tiger Woods he
just after seven years of losing losing
losing he finally won a tournament a
couple weeks ago and as we hope that
keeps that streak up back in the 1920s
there's a gang fight between the
terrible terrible gangs in Chicago in
New York and they called it the st.
Valentine's Day Massacre there are seven
dead in a single day two gangsters from
one gang and five gangsters from another
game they called it the st. Valentine's
Day Massacre they farmed the FBI the FBI
did not exist before this gunfight okay
they formed the FBI to deal with gang
warfare the United States get rid of the
mafioso medal doctors killed 688 people
every day and the government does
nothing 59 percent of Americans run five
or more prescription drugs because you
have insurance when grandma was paying
the doctor of the pumpkin pie we didn't
have such problems but now you have
insurance they keep piling on drugs
because insurance pays and nobody
complains medical errors are the third
leading cause of death in America
medical errors in hospitals by doctors
are the third leading cause of death in
America each year in America medical
doctors killed 250 1000 people in the
hospital by mistake every four years
they kill 1 million patients what would
happen if Taco Bell were to kill 250 one
thousand customers in a year what would
happen if United Airlines already killed
two hundred fifty one thousand
passengers in a year what would happen
if North Korea are
Rann were to send over a fleet of
intercontinental ballistic missiles with
nuclear warheads and killed 250 1,000
Americans it be war here's one trade
that does it every year they don't even
get an ocean ticket because nobody
complains this happened in Orlando
Florida this Latino girl was having her
first baby she going to a County
Hospital cuz she was low income and she
going into labor she calls the hospitals
Hammond labor I'm gonna come to the
hospital so he buzz the doctor he's
playing golf he says well she has her
first baby
she'll be in labor a long time give me a
call later Vicky calms him all this
baby's coming now you must come here so
he shows up at the house when he cuts
their arms and legs off then he delivers
the baby
six months later he does it again to
another woman who interrupted his golf
game
yes maternity hospitals are the worst in
the industrialized world over 50,000
each year these are women healthy women
healthy women who go to have their
babies maternity hospitals suffer from
severe and permanent injuries and 800
die every year from injuries in the
hospital America is the worst in the
industrialized nation three point three
six trillion in health care that's why
you don't see stories about mafioso
anymore as a mafioso they go to medical
school
and they want to kill somebody they have
somebody hit them with a car then bring
him in they kill them as a patient and
they get away with it because doctors
kill patients all the time as health
care weighs 750 billion three quarters
of a trillion dollars every year sugar
is your worst enemy sugars your worst
enemy it causes plaque in your arteries
causes cancer causes behavioral problems
in depression foie gras a French
delicacy fatty liver and ducks and geese
they used it like a spread on their pond
and their butter and
Retin humans are now getting fatty
livers foie gras three-year-old babies
are having to have liver transplants
because they get too much sugar when you
have liver spots or age spots in the
back your hands your face your neck you
have millions I'm on the inside your
brain your lungs your heart your liver
they cause cancer they're caused by
Fritos comida pretty toes Papa's feet to
spoil Fritos
Pisco mm-hmm Monte Kia oil coconut oil
olive oil MCT oil margin a human brain
with dementia senile dementia it should
be white snow white like vanilla ice
cream it's the same color as liver spots
and age spots does the same chemical
there are no genetic diseases no genetic
diseases that was a false theory Charles
Darwin knew that people passed on
information Gregor Mendel is a
mathematician
we passed your discovers that bugs kill
people not little gods sitting on
planets up in the sky because people
thought oh we need to burn more things
to make the gods happy if we don't make
the gods happy with all these things
that we're burning to them that they
will send the terrible disease upon us
but past year found out oh it's about
it's about causing this birth defects
are caused by not genetics 99% of all
birth defects are caused by vitamin
mineral deficiencies during pregnancy
99% of women do not take prenatal
vitamins until they miss two or three
cycles the baby's already damaged by
them by the time they go to the doctor
to keep our kids from dying before us
you must give these young people the 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12ms 2 3 fatty acids before
they get pregnant
otherwise you will be burying your
children your grandchildren
James Watson Francis Crick proposed that
the structure of DNA was the double
helix 1953 1962 nine years later they
got the Nobel Prize for that and over a
50-year period
100 trillion with a T 100 trillion
dollars was spent looking for prevention
and cures for genetic diseases they
never found any because there are no
Jake diseases sickle cell anemia occurs
in black people white people Latinos red
people yellow people
hummingbirds flamingos giraffe ramps all
animals all people all vertebrates get
sickle cell anemia is not a genetic
disease of black people it's not a
genetic disease it's a birth defect mom
is missing a nutrient when the bone
marrow cells are farming in the embryo
in pregnancy and so when the baby's born
it only produces dysfunctional red blood
cells the death of the genetic disease
transmission 1977 epigenetics as the
science is replacing genetics
epigenetics you'll see why in a moment
the death of the genetic theory disease
transmission black gene lies we could
have another book Latino gene lies hmm
because there are no genetic diseases in
Latinos how pressure is not genetic
cancer is not genetic diabetes is not
genetic obesity is not genetic heart
disease not genetic
cancer is not genetic pastor Creflo
Dollar from Atlanta Georgia
great pastor churches all over the world
this picture shows his daughter there
was 30 years old in that picture I was
introduced to him on the phone when she
was only 11 years old and she had asthma
asthma the doctors told pastor Donald
that she had a genetic form of asthma
found in black kids and she was going to
die and they called me I said no there's
no Jake disease and black kids and she
has a deficiency of one nutrient so
we're gonna get her on a gluten-free
diet to maximize the absorption of that
nutrient in two weeks time she was
now 20 years later she a beautiful young
woman has several grandchildren pastor
dollars happy faith without works is
dead Pastor Mike Freeman from Baltimore
Maryland about five years ago when the
bird flu went for Baltimore Marin
hundreds of people were dying there's
one hospital there was ten men who had
less than 24 hours to live the doctors
just put him in the room so that nobody
would waste time on because they're
gonna be dead by morning pastor Freeman
was gonna die by morning so they put him
in that room with his ten other men
Linda Linda Tyler his techie person at
his church who did all his techie work
with computers and things calls me
crying says can you help Pastor Freeman
he's only got minutes and hours maybe to
live can you help him yeah I want you to
take our plant minerals just our plain
unflavored plant and minerals the liquid
minerals or colloidal minerals which is
so washed Claus with him and put him on
his legs and I want you to pray for him
for four hours to pray for him for four
hours it's because I want you to stay in
the room when the nurses and doctors
aren't in there you take the covers up
and you keep wetting those those towels
that are wet with the mineral the ones
to go through skin they leave the room
you wet them again you start praying you
don't let the doctors near them because
they'll take the they'll take those
towels off of him after four hours
you're gonna go she calls me the next
morning screaming I thought oh god he's
dead she says he's cured he got locked
out everybody else died ten died one
walked out alive and the only one who's
getting the plant Middle's on the skin
faith without works is dead we must do
our part you cannot do bad things and
expect God to heal you we must do our
part